people little chairs got a problem we'll
fix it we don't care what your injury is
you got the desire we'll get you off the
sidewalk my name is Brad Sud I'm the
owner of camp chair you got kids and
have a football game at a muddy field
prosit you want to go fishing with your
buddies go fishing if it snows our
chairs float right over the snow it's no
problem he goes basically it's get off
the couch and go enjoy life
she was crying one day after her injury
and she couldn't go camping anymore her
exact words or go on without me I find
that unacceptable so I told her I would
build her something took me two years
and a bunch of beer in my garage to
figure out the first model but since
then with now my applied science we've
been making leaps and bounds a bunch of
Engineers told me it couldn't be done
and I still went ahead and did it
take the most expensive one I put out
there is a 53,000 but that one can
almost do your dishes I'm not a big fan
of this disposable world on all these
parts so we've actually made us a single
last 15-20 years made them tough
literally you can shoot mine they still
work all the money that we make goes
back into the research and development
we'll sit down we'll come up with a
problem and we'll try and make a
solution that's the big thing in the
room everybody can whine and cry about
stuff critics are so easy to find you
can you can't swing a dead cat without
hitting one however finding some of it
actually comes up with the solutions
will we tape writing
Betty Jeanne's legs don't work properly
she can't walk loves her horses to death
big smile on her face all the time she
had an unfortunate death with her
husband kids are out of the house so it
is just her in the wheelchair taking
care of the farm I always go back and I
check on her and she didn't have the
money to buy a new chair so we sold her
a youth chair but we retrofitted it so
if the horses got spooked while she was
training them she wouldn't have to worry
about the tank in her tummy and she can
still get out and take care of the farm
if she couldn't do that then you know
the farm go away the mentality is
there's just you know her body can't
keep up so we're gonna we're gonna fix
that money does not drive me this is all
about you know the smiles on people's
faces and you know the families that
I've helped basically we figure out how
much we need for overhead and parts we
take that money we put it in the next
one we have no debt against the company
we do everything out of pocket if we
need the parts we go down and pay for it
we don't take credit it's cash money and
you know we'll get it done I'm not rich
but I have a lot of fun
he's got one of the worst injuries but
it's about the mind and what do you want
to do right now he's in flight school so
a full quad and he's out there the guy's
just amazing hey you want to get up here
with that he's got a little boy and the
little boy has only known his dad being
paralyzed
oh yeah we going in the mud kids hauling
butt across the grass and here comes
Chris you know he's chasing his son so
little things like that just make this
whole job worth it that can go
everywhere now these troops went out and
gave everything I'm a combat vet myself
I was lucky enough to walk off the field
with all my parts see my brothers and
sisters coming over without their parts
any time you look around and great
nation was built because of those people
I'm not a big rah-rah type of guys I
just I get more pleasure watching other
people have fun and just you see a kid
smile or you know you see happiness and
the tears of it I I can't really
describe it is just it's just man I
can't tell I guess it's really cool
you